Used to be said that in the old wars
fought by the Irish clans that they had an
agreement. I Dunno if this
is true, but I love the idea.
Doesn't matter how much they slaughtered
themselves with broad swords and knives
and whatever else the maniacs used,
that they should always spare the poets.
Don't kill the poets because the policy
had to be left to tell the story.
Most great poets don't go to war.
They right.
This week you're reading a great poet.
He all Dr. Rowe,
okay.
A poet and prose,
the poet and fiction.
Dr. Rowe is some of you must know is a
famous American writer for his historical
fiction.
Much of his fiction is
often very historical and
you'll find if any one takes
the time someday,
that large chunks of the monologue you
hear from William Tecumseh Sherman and
this novel is directly
out of his famous memoir.
And then every now and then Dr. Rowe
will embellish or add a few lines.
Most of the people in this book,
we're real people,
but there are some invented in some ways
possibly the most brilliant inventions
in this book are the slave characters or
the Friedman character and what doctor
road does with them through this sort
of anguished crucible of all out war
look, especially for those
journeys into Sherman Zone, mine,
Sherman's psyche,
those meditations of Sherman's on death
page 88 and 89 to be exact is I think an
unforgettable meditation by Sherman on
the meaning of death and just what it
means and why.
He in some ways enjoys it.
Herman Melville wrote a whole bunch
of poems during the civil war.
He was one of the poets spared.
It wasn't very famous yet.
As you know,
for Moby Dick that was to come later.
Maybe our greatest writer,
the 19th century also wrote a
lot of poetry and he wrote all,
most all of his poetry
during the civil war.
As did,
by the way Emily Dickinson,
I don't know if any of
your Emily Dickinson fans,
but Emily the Belle of
Amherst road between 901,000
poems in her life and fully
two thirds of them in the
four years of the war.
She became obsessed with
the idea of the war.
And if you read it closely enough,
it's all over her wartime poetry.
She became obsessed with it.
Death.
Our greatest death poet
was of course Whitman.
More from him later,
but one little uh,
piece by Melville cause it's about you.
This was Melville's meditation and poetry
on the death of college students in
the war.
It's called on the saline collegians.
It's timeless.
It could be about any war,
although collegians
don't go to war anymore
very much in America,
youth is the time when hearts are large
and stirring wars appeal to the spirit
which appeals and turn
to the bladed draws.
If woman in sight and duty show though
made the mask of cane or whether it'd be
truth sacred,
because who can aloof remain that shares
youths ardor uncool by the snow of
wisdom or sorted gain wool for the homes
of the north and wolf for the seats of
the south.
All who felt life spring and prime and
were swept by the wind of their place in
time.
I'll lavish hearts on whichever
side of birth or Bain or courage,
high arm them for the stirring wars,
armed them some to die.
Apollo like in pride.
Each slay his python caught
the maxims in his temple,
taught the anguish of maternal
hearts must search for bone divine,
but well the Stripling's bore,
they're faded parts. The heaven.
All parts must assign, never
felt lives, care or cloy.
Each bloomed and died and unabated boy
nor dreamed what death was thought at
mears sliding into some vernal sphere.
They knew the joy,
but leap the grief like plants,
that flower air comes the leaf which
storms lay low and kindly doom and kill
them and the flush of their balloon.
Okay.
The casualties in the union army alone
and the army of the Potomac grants army
from the 1st of May
through the end of July,
1864 and this horrible war of attrition
and the stalemate it produced in
Virginia.
The casualties in that one arm and about
two to two and a half months was 66,000
men is the largest loss of life in
the shortest period of time and all of
American military history.
How did it get to that?
Why did
the war go on and on and on?
Well,
let's begin with grants and Lee.
These two great warriors
around whose names,
symbols, actions, decisions,
a good deal of the war would hinge
in the past in the final year,
grant from his successes in the West fall
of Vicksburg and fall of Chattanooga,
the victory at Chickamauga came east,
appointed by Abraham Lincoln
as general of the army.
Congress actually revived a special
rank that hadn't used in years called
lieutenant general and
then just for grant,
he came,
Easton was appointed head of all union
armies on any front anywhere in March of
1864 winter 64
he was wined and dined at the White
House and wined and dined and congress.
They had to keep telling him
to put on a decent uniform.
There's a lot of truth to this idea of
grant that kind of humbled Puglian he had
off. They're all been doing nothing but
work in his brother's leather shop and
Galena, Illinois. When the war broke out.
Yeah,
but boy did he have a nose for war.
Okay.
It was a great horseman.
Cantor like nobody else and Gallup like
nobody else and he loved his horses.
Been to west point.
The only thing he really got good
grades in a West Point were painting and
drawing. He nearly failed some
of the military science courses,
some of his biographers of act and made
a big deal out of that that because he
hadn't studied hard and a genre
and i's Germany's manuals,
those manuals of combat
tactics and strategy. Okay.
That he was there for a freer
to simply invent as he went.
I don't know.
This war made grant at the
same time he made the war.
Okay.
He may have been as many
of his bar and by the way,
there's been an industry of grant
biographies in the past 10 to 15 years.
He's been rediscovered after a long period
in our history when he just vanished
and the country forgot that the,
oh by the way,
the Union won the war and
there was that guy grant.
Okay.
There are far, far, far more
monuments to Robert E. Lee.
Yeah.
And the American landscape and
they're already Ulysses grant.
I'll try to explain that.
At the end of the course is cash.
Tony rates in these,
this last year of the war were ghastly
and horrible and it nearly led to a
sufficient of war weariness across
the north and discussed and just an
overwhelmed kind of spirit that it was
entirely possible by July and August of
64 if certain events
hadn't quickly followed,
that the north collectively would have
given up the war and sued for peace.
Okay.
But grant developed essentially
a strategy of victory.
And here's what it was. He did it in
conjunction with William Tecumseh Sherman,
Philip Sheridan, uh, the or the of
the previous general of the army,
Henry Halleck and most
importantly with Lincoln himself.
And that strategy was basically this.
And it was just the first
to determine that Richmond,
the capitol of the confederacy was not
to be the objective of the war in the
east, taken an enemy's
capital, not that important.
Secondly,
grant grasped as does Sherman the
political character of this war,
that this was now war to be won or lost
in public opinion because it had become
all out because it was now a
war upon people upon resources.
It depended deeply upon morale.
And the will of either side
to somehow see it through
third grant and Sherman especially
determined that this would now be a war on
southern resources.
The destruction of slavery of course,
becomes a major part of that.
And one of the great ironies of the
wars that Sherman never ever for a day
wanted to free a slave
as he told his officer,
ain't gonna be no niggers and
uncle Billy's army, sorry.
That's what he said. Uh, he wasn't
in to having black soldiers. In fact,
there were no black soldiers who actually
served in Sherman's army in Georgia.
There will be thousands upon thousands
of Friedman following his army and it
will force him to a situation of
a recognition that will it or not,
he's crushing the spirit of the south to
destroy slavery and ultimately kind of
admits it.
Look for that in Dr. Rowe
in the east,
the object of the war now was to be Lee's
army to fight Lee's army anywhere on
ground,
especially that the northern troops
could somehow choose to try to spring Lee
out of his trench works that he would
build everywhere they would stop.
And to simply kill as many
confederates as possible,
to force the south to quit.
It was to be a war on an army,
not for a strategic capital,
strategic and rivers and
so on would be important.
The object now was to destroy the fighting
force of the south and it's fighting
will
and in the western part of the war and
there were actually five major armies.
Now the grant was to try to coordinate
and army under Nathanial banks out in the
far west.
Lincoln wanted to go into Texas with,
they never really got into Texas.
What grant wanted eventually,
excuse me one second.
What grant wanted was it the army on
her Nathanial banks in Louisiana to move
east to take mo bill the last remaining
great southern port and then come
smashing right through the deep south
across Alabama and Georgia as Sherman's
army,
as we'll see in a minute,
was invading northern Georgia toward
Atlanta and sort of just invade the whole
middle heartland of the south
until the south would give up.
And in Virginia, grant took
battlefield command. He didn't have to,
he could've stayed at a desk
in Washington, but it was by,
it was quite decidedly not his style.
He went into the field as the
commander of the army of the Potomac.
Now on the other side in Robert E.
Lee,
the south had without a question,
we've said this before and there
is so much been written on this,
you can't count it all. The south had a
great general and Lee, a daring general,
even in spite of his
tremendous defeated Gettysburg,
or actually they did tender his
resignation that Davis didn't accept and
couldn't accept.
Lee was already a legend,
is men saw him as almost godlike.
He was beautiful.
They said he was gorgeous,
he was handsome.
No one ever looked quite likely in a
uniform. Well, that curly white hair.
There's a brand new biography out that
I recently reviewed by a woman named
Elizabeth prior.
It's just one the Abraham Lincoln prize.
There's another lovely irony book
on Lee Warren is the Lincoln Prize.
That's reconciliation.
It's called reading the man.
Okay.
I was like a title of a porn
movie or something, but, sorry,
scratch that Jen.
But she did the book from
Lee's voluminous letters.
He was a tremendous letter
writer throughout his life.
Lifetime officer,
Sun of Light Horse,
Harry leave the American revolution fame.
His father had been a total scoundrel.
He had a brother that was
an even greater scoundrel.
His brother and probably
his father fathered children
by slave women and abandon
their homes, their wives, their
families. He came from a very,
very difficult sorted but aristocratic
famous Virginia family and he went to
West Point just like his daddy
and he became an officer in his early
twenties he spent his twenties his
thirties in his forties spread
all over the United States,
largely as an engineer.
He was a great engineer.
He helped build the first
bridge across the Mississippi.
He helped redirect rivers in the
lower Mississippi and on and on.
He spent probably two thirds of his life
up until the civil war, away from home,
away from that mansion that sits
today and Arlington Cemetery.
Arlington house was Lee's home.
He inherited it by marrying into it.
He married a Custus. He married into
the family of George Washington,
extended family of George Washington,
and of course it is Lee's own home,
Arlington that before the war and ended
the United States government confiscated
Lee's wife to say the least,
never got over this.
They confiscated Lee's home and converted
it into the largest national cemetery
and the country.
Did you ever go to Arlington,
go to Arlington House,
or at least remember that that was founded
to bury the thousands and thousands
of union dead killed by Lee's army.
At any rate,
he may have hated war in the abstract,
but his biographers have taken us into
least psyche and some useful ways.
I won't say all of these many biographies,
but some of them have really shown us
a complicated man of great daring and
audacity and aggressiveness.
He always wanted to be on the off fences.
He hated being entrenched.
He hated being on the defensive and
he clearly saw war as an emotional or
psychological release.
Okay. I think a little led,
properly taken is good for a man.
He said that was in the Mexican war.
Then say that during the civil war,
surveying the fetal of slaughter at
Fredericksburg and December is 62,
he said famously,
it is well that wars so terrible so
that we did not grow too fond of it.
He appeared to um, to,
to change in battle. Uh,
his eyes would be like fire people said,
and English journalist observer
in the Battle of the wilderness.
So horrible battle fought and
dense woods observe this of Lee.
No Man who at the terrible moments saw
his flashing eyes and sternly set lips is
ever likely to forget them. The light
of battles still flaming in his eye.
And there are lots of
people who said that about
the debate about Lee's
essentially among his story,
his Elise is essentially whether he
bled the south to death, so to speak,
with his aggressiveness is two major
invasions of the north and the costs that
meant to the confederacy or whether he
was the true military genius of American
history and only through that offensive
daring that the confederacy survive as
long as it did or only through his
devotion and his maneuverability of huge
numbers of men across
difficult landscapes.
Did the confederacy survive as long as
it did through 1864 and his struggle
against grants army,
which are numbered him at times
two to one in 1864 in 1865
but he hated being on the defensive.
Now in 1864 I will strike that
man a blow in the morning.
I will strike that man a blow in the
morning. He would say sometimes yes,
that night in his camp,
even if he wasn't planning to do it.
Now
the campaign of 1864 the
pivotal in so many ways,
decisive, despite the fact that
it becomes a horrible stalemate.
The decisive campaign of the civil
war in everyone's hopes in the north.
The campaign, once again,
that would only be one summer,
was launched in April and May of 64
but it wasn't going to end that summer.
It would end in a horrible stalemate
in a siege of the city of Petersburg,
uh,
just south of Richmond.
And the war of course would not end until
the following spring for April's into
the war. But here's roughly
what happened. And by the way,
I refer you here to the Ken Burns film
series and there's of course a very good
reason it burns,
decided in this nine part film series
to give to whole parts to the year 1864.
I have my own little
criticisms of that film series,
which I'll be happy to share
with you at some point,
but I thought it was actually
quite brilliant the way
he just makes you agonize
to get out of 1864.
I mean God,
how long must 1864 less because that's
actually the way the country feel
in the battle of the wilderness.
May Five,
six 1864 the two armies
basically collided just west of,
of uh,
Fredericksburg in a densely densely
wooded area that was known at that time as
the wilderness.
They essentially just bumped into one
another cause there were only two roads
and went north,
south or east or west through this area.
And they fought it out
and woods for two days.
It was a totally disorganized battle.
Often men would only fire at what they
saw other weapons firing cause they could
really never see their enemies and
hence sometimes killed her own men.
And the most horrible thing
about the wilderness, of course,
as you perhaps have heard,
is that hundreds if not thousands of
wounded and ended up being burned to death
in the woods because the woods caught on
fire in several places and the wounded
could not be retrieved.
Soldiers on both sides lay down at night,
make shift trench, works along roadways
and listened to their comrades,
scream as they were burning to death.
In the woods and could not save them.
Yeah.
In two days of,
uh,
of a really thoroughly disorganize
slug fest in woods grants,
Army lost 18,400 casualties,
dead and wounded.
Lee lost about 11,000 dead and wounded
and it appeared that Lee had once again
for what the fourth time now stopped a
union army invading into Virginia and at
that union army would probably have to
retreat back out of this densely wooded
wilderness.
Get up north of the Rappahannock,
regroup again again,
again as the army of the
Potomac always had. Yeah.
What happened was of course,
grant never intended to stop.
No matter what happened.
He had the obvious advantage of manpower.
He had tremendous resources behind him.
Although that manpower was risky
because of that very summer,
the three year lists, they weren't up by
May, but they're going to be up in June,
the three year enlistments from 61 to 64,
the great mass of the army of the Potomac.
I've been in those who
had survived the veterans,
the real soldiers I've been in for three
years, and their terms would be up.
How in the hell to get these men to re
enlist. When they were in during this
and the government came up
with three and $400 bounties,
they came up with 30 day furloughs,
hearing their percentages of regimen sent
home to do anything to get these guys
to reenlist and Lincoln call
for 500,000 more volunteers.
I half a million.
Now they will actually eventually
get almost that half million men,
but the problem as the union army,
he's realized that summer is that these
new soldiers broadened by being paid
bounties and all sorts of other things
were terrible soldiers and grant counted
by July and August.
These new recruits that about three of
every four became deserters the first
time they face combat.
So that manpower was not a certain thing.
The grant just kept moving
and there's the famous story.
It's the night of the second day.
It's the fifth or 6th of May 64 and you,
most of the Union army is camped along
a roadway, a north south roadway.
They've just fought the two worst
days of the wharf. They've survived,
they're depleted.
Woods are burning.
They expect any moment to
all have to retreat north.
And there came grant with just a few
members of his staff cantering down the
road heading south.
He didn't stopped to say anything
to anybody in him tip his hat,
probably spit from his cigar.
And as they saw him moving south, they
began to realize they weren't retreating.
And for about a mile and
a half along this roadway,
these scarred soldiers started to get
up and scream and holler at the top of
their loan for grants for granted.
They were going south and they did the
rest of this terrible campaign would be
an attempt by grant now to outmaneuver
Lee to try to keep moving left grants
left to try to get around Lee's army
to move faster than Lee if possible.
And ultimately to cut off lease supply
line either to Richmond or further south
from Richmond and if possible,
forget about taken Richmond,
but to try to cut off Lee's
army from the rest of the south
and if possible with Sheridan's army in
the Shenandoah valley cut him off from
the West.
So when grant gets accused of
being a butcher that summer,
there's some truth to that,
but it really was a war of
maneuver, maneuver, maneuver.
They collided.
They actually,
the first attempt was to see who could
get first to this crossroads called
Spotsylvania courthouse
and it Spotsylvania.
They fought for about six,
seven consecutive days.
This was the rehearsal for World War One.
Everywhere the army stopped,
they dug the deepest possible trenches
they could and it's possible date veiny
indeed.
Lee's army got there just before grants
army and they built this incredible
trench work that was in new u shape.
And for about six days,
grant's army just made one frontal
assault on this after another.
And it produced these horrifying scenes
of the dead and wounded three and four
deep in these trenches,
day after day after day.
Most of it fought in rainstorms
at Spotsylvania when you add it all up,
okay?
Uh,
they first encountered each other and
the 8th of May and it didn't really stop
fighting there though
about the 19th of May,
grant's army lost almost
30,000 casualties.
Lee's army,
almost 20,000 casualties.
And yet grant just kept moving
and kept moving left and south,
left in south,
and then grant the first week of June
would make his greatest mistake of the
war.
And he admitted it is the only place in
his great to volume memoir when he used
the word regret and he
really regretted cold harbor
at cold harbor.
Grand had misinformation.
He somehow did not understand how much
of Lee's army had actually concentrated
in front of him. And somehow
he missed, saw the landscape.
He didn't realize that Lee's army on
each flank had a river and those rivers
were pretty high. It was, you know, may
June. And there was no way to flank him.
So he just made on the 3rd of June,
uh,
the largest frontal
assault tack of the war,
there were 50,000 union
troops engaged in this
and grants army took 7,000
casualties in a half hour.
Yeah.
And many of them in, and they'd been
fighting not day after day after day.
And God only knows what fatalist
soldiers become in that circumstance.
They were asked before the attack had
cold Harvard dependent pin their names and
home addresses on their shirts.
At least much of the Union army was,
and they did.
They had no dog tags and in that war
they were told to pin their names on
themselves so they can
be identified when dead.
And I believe Burns uses
this story in the film.
It was one union soldier who
etched into his diary morning,
June 3rd I died today at cold harbor
and he did
this stopped grants movement.
It protected Richmond.
It meant that the war would now go on
and on through that summer rather than
attempting anymore
assault on Lee's forces,
which we're now constantly digging
trenches, digging trenches,
digging trenches all around the eastern
side of Richmond grand kept moving south
and this time he got to Petersburg
faster than Lee or at least most of Lee's
army.
And by
mid to late June they put
the city of Petersburg,
just some 25 miles south of Richmond
under siege and Petersburg would be going,
you can see many of these great
photographs and burns. His film series.
Photographers went crazy in 64 and 65
photographing these giant trench works,
these trench cities that
were built around Petersburg.
There would be a quick attempt to break
the siege of Petersburg and was known as
the battle of the crater.
Quick in the sense about a month after
grants army concentrated all around the
east side on the south side of Petersburg.
They were always trying to cut Lee's
supply lines off either west or south.
Never managed to completely
do it until the next spring.
But you may know the story
of the battle of the crater.
Some coal miners in the 48th Pennsylvania
went to their colonel who went to his
general. I went to general Burnside
who went to grant and said,
we can dig a tunnel 500 yards under the
confederate line and we'll fill it with
tons of dynamite and we can
do it with ventilation stats.
We know how to do these things and
I will blow the confederate line to
Smithereens. Let us do it. And at first
grant and his staff said, no, no, no, no.
This is too crazy.
They sat down with them,
they convinced and they
could do it and they did it
500 yards of a tunnel.
They ventilated the confederates and the
other side and the lines in some areas
here, we're never more than
150 to 200 yards apart.
Okay?
Nah, they actually did hear
some digging were told later,
but they didn't know what the hell it was
and
then they dug a countertrend
at the end inside or a tunnel.
They put in four tons of dynamite
fuses you to this day can see the opening
to that tunnel and you can still see
the suppression in the
landscape where the crater was.
And then July 30th,
1864 they blew it up
and they blew up an area of the
confederate line about 200 yards long,
men's bodies were simply
exploded into the air.
It's the opening scene of cold mountain.
If you've seen the movie not bad.
One of the best parts of that movie,
actually
I thought Nicole Kidman was badly cast.
I don't know about you.
When you're suffering,
you haven't got enough to eat
and you're laying in the snow.
You can't look like Nicole
Kidman. I'm sorry, any right.
But the problem was the battle of
crater became a union disaster.
Instead of exploiting this is they should
have and been far, far more organized.
They should have managed to get
around this crater. Actually,
they didn't even understand how big this
gigantic hole in the ground would be.
A huge hole in the confederate line has
been exploded hundreds of yards wide,
but union troops started marching
into the whole, I'm not kidding,
and within an hour or two as
confederates regrouped and sheer shock,
they said it was just like picking off
fish in a bowl and they stood all around
this giant hole in the ground and forth.
4,000 Union troops will killed
in the battle of the crater,
which it turned out to
be a union disaster.
Now
out west,
where's Sherman?
There he is.
Can we see this
now?
The other major campaign of the war that
of course will ultimately lead to union
victory.
And I won't get as quite to the dead
end of the war today by any means,
but it is of course, William Sherman's
Atlanta campaign through northern Georgia,
fall of Atlanta by September of 64 the
campaign lasted all that summer at the
same time.
The stalemate sets in in Virginia around
Petersburg where these thousands of
casualties and you must, you
must try, if you can imagine,
northerners standing and post offices
and telegraph offices all over the towns
of the Midwest and New England waiting
for casualty report and the adjutants of
regiments writing the list,
standing in a small town post office
and the Telegraph comes through with the
list of the dead dozen,
two dozen,
three dozen men from a town
that only had a thousand people.
It was beginning to
destroy northern morale
and things weren't that much
better and Virgin Georgia.
So it seems throughout that summer.
Sherman,
finally outmaneuvered General
Joseph Johnston's confederate
army toward Atlanta,
one at Kennesaw mountain in
two days in June in June,
late June of [inaudible] 64
and essentially put Atlanta
on under siege in July
and August and kept trying
to get around around, around,
especially to the left to the east and
south Atlanta to cut off the supply lines
to this biggest city in
the heartland of the south.
He finally succeeded at great costs
once when Atlanta fell on the 4th of
September in 64 and the fall of Atlanta is
in some ways both strategically
and in terms of morale,
one of the most important little turning
points of the war because it has a huge
impact on the political situation and
the election of 64 about to occur.
More on that in a second.
It was then that Sherman,
based on this strategy of conquest,
destruction of resources
and war upon people
made the decision really quite quickly
to launch his march to the sea.
It took him a couple of
months to organize it,
but from November 15th to Christmas Eve,
that's about five weeks.
Sherman's Army March 285 miles from
Atlanta to Savannah with 62,000 troops.
They were almost unopposed
general John B hoods,
confederate army that had surrendered
in effect given up Atlanta had retreated
south to fight again and hoods idea would
actually without Jefferson Davis was
approval while the Sherman was going to
invade toward the east toward the sea
and destroyed Georgia Hood.
Took an army of about 30,000 men
and invaded backup into Tennessee,
hoping the chairman would stop
and come after him. Chairman said,
let him go.
Yeah.
It was a kind of a game now of time,
resources,
destruction,
who would give up?
We are not fighting a hostile army
anymore. Sherman said, I'm quoting him,
were fighting on hostile people
is aim and objective now with the civilian
population and Americans had never
made war on civilians quite
like Sherman would in Georgia.
We cannot change the hearts of those
people. Sherman wrote of the south,
but we can make wars so terrible
and make them so sick of war.
The generations will pass before
they will ever again appeal to it.
Okay.
Up in the Shenandoah valley.
Philip Sheridan's Union army under
similar orders to make war on society,
gave a simple order to his officers
and most of that arm, it was cavalry.
His order was put in the
starkest of total war terms.
He said, quote leaves them
only eyes with which to weep.
This was now savage war
to win the war with fear was Sherman's
goal to win it with destruction and to
win it with maneuver.
Freed slaves swarmed to behind
Sherman's army. He hated it.
He didn't want him to be there.
He didn't know what to do with them.
The hell am I gonna do with these people.
First it was five thousand ten thousand
fifteen he had 25 to 30,000 refugees,
slaves tailing right behind his army. It's
about half the size of his whole army.
Follow that in.
Dr. Rowe
Sherman didn't always a play kindness,
her niceness with him.
Okay.
At one point,
his troops lifted up the pontoon bridge
across a river and scores of Friedman
trying to get across with
them drowned in the river.
Sherman's attitude was,
it's where it goes.
They made it by Christmas Eve
to Savannah just before that,
into Liberty County,
just south of Savannah and till
this day in Liberty County, Georgia.
Okay.
There are plenty of people around.
I have a former student who lives there
and runs a historic site who will tell
you this is where Sherman turned left.
Okay.
And you think, well, okay, I'm gonna
spend a left turn sign or something.
This is where Sherman turn left.
I also never forget the time I
was doing research and the colon,
the Caroliniana collections
and the Columbia South
Carolina and I don't remember
exactly what I asked for and the Arco.
It's been a good week there.
I don't remember. Oh, I, it was records
about the state capitol and the buildings.
I want her to know about the ruins and
destruction and I asked for this stuff.
An archivist who was a woman looked
up from the desk admin. She said,
don't have it.
Sherman burnt it.
Okay,
thank you very much.
I won't be able to look
at that stuff apparently.
Now,
if you follow the purple line here,
of course you realize
that this is the destined,
is the route of Sherman's.
This is about 280 miles
from Atlanta to the sea.
Okay?
It would give us some of the best songs
of the war marching through Georgia.
It also gave the civil war.
It's anti antihero.
It's principal villain of union victory.
Some say the architect of total war.
Oh,
that's a little too much for
a short delay only on Sherman,
but it was now a war of
conquest and destruction.
He did not destroy Savannah,
but when he got to Charleston,
well actually
much of Charleston,
he didn't have to destroy because it
was being destroyed already by union
gunboats and artillery
from around the harbor.
But the city he did destroy was Columbia.
The capital of South Carolina,
which was burned to the ground
as by the way, was Atlanta. Now,
Sherman would always say these were
just fires that broke out because of
extensive shelling.
That was not the case in Columbia.
They burned about everything
that was standing in Colombia.
And then they kept moving north north,
North into North Carolina.
And I'll come back to that later.
Cause the final,
final surrender of the civil war
of course came in North Carolina.
Not In Virginia.
No.
Before we get to app a Maddix,
I'm gonna save the CG Petersburg,
the lifting of Peter's at the siege
and the march two apoe Maddix and the
surrender for Thursday.
Cause it makes a perfect segue back into
wartime reconstruction plans because
that, the nature of that surrender at
Appomattox is a great deal to do with,
uh,
the kind of reconstruction ideas and
plans that were boiling as early as 1863
really out of congress
and from Lincoln himself.
And let me just end with this little story
I mentioned that Terman, you
know, made it to the theater.
Havana march part of his
troops up to Charleston,
took Charleston seed bed of
succession and all of that. Uh,
although actually Charleston didn't fully
fall to union hands until February of
65.
It had been bombarded throughout the
last eight to nine months, as I said,
from union ships and guns
all around the harbor.
And if you've ever been to Charleston,
that glorious, beautiful colonial city,
that Caribbean city as it looks,
all those mentions about 15 to
20 blocks up from the harbor,
you must imagine it almost completely
in ruined by early 1865 all the white
people evacuated and abandoned the city
and the only people left principally
were slaves, Freedman, thousands of them.
And they in effect took over the city.
The First Union regiment that marched up
meeting street in Charleston was a 21st
USC tea colored infantry of black regimen
and they accepted the surrender of the
city from its mayor.
And then they began to hold ceremonies.
The black folks or Charleston,
the beginning hold ceremonies
all around the city.
They held a parade, um, in late March,
or was it early April of 65 they had this
huge parade where they had two floats
and they had him on one float.
They had a little slave auction occurring
emoc slave auction with a woman with
her baby being sold away.
And on the next float they had a
coffin labeled slavery and it said Fort
Sumpter, Doug, it's
grave. April 12th, 1861.
And then they play on one more
ceremony. And, and by the way, the war,
when it finally finally, finally ended,
they held an extraordinary ceremony,
a ceremony on Fort Sumpter.
Um,
they crammed about 3000 people
onto the little island. Uh,
all kinds of dignitaries
came. Now, general Anderson,
not the colonel who had surrendered
the Ford four years ago,
came and raise the u s flag four years,
almost to the day he had taken it down.
William Lloyd garrison
was there from the north,
the great abolitionists who
wept uncontrollably when
he heard us a small black
children's choir sing John Brown's body.
And the very negative of that ceremony,
which was the 14th of April,
they held a banquet of a sword in a
building that had a roof on it back in
Charleston. And that was
the very night, of course,
that Lincoln was assassinated
at Ford's theater in Washington.
But the black folks of Charleston
had planned one more ceremony.
Yeah,
that's ceremony was a burial ceremony.
It turns out that during
the last months of the war,
the confederate army turn the
planters horse track a race course.
It was called the Washington race
course into an open air cemetery,
uh, excuse me, prison.
And in that open air prison in the
Infield of the horse track about 260 odd
union soldiers that died of disease
and exposure and they were buried in
unmarked graves in a mass grave site out
behind the grand Stan of the race track.
And by the way,
there was no more important and symbolic
site and low country planters slave
holding life than their race track.
Okay.
All the black folks with Charleston got
organized. They knew about all of this.
They went to the site, they reentered
all the graves, the barrier, the men,
they couldn't mark them with names and
they didn't have any names and they made
them proper graves.
And then they built a fence all
the way around the cemetery,
about a hundred yards long and 50,
60 yards deep.
And they whitewash the
fence and over an archway.
They painted the inscription
martyrs of the race course
and then on May 1st,
1865 they held a parade of
10,000 people on the race track,
led by 3000 black children carrying arm
loads of and singing John Brown's body
followed then by black women. Then by
black men. It was regimented this way.
Then by contingents of union infantry,
everybody marched all the way around
the race track as many as could fit gut
into the grave site.
Five black preachers read from scripture,
a children's choir sang the
national anthem of America,
the beautiful and several spirituals
and then they broke from that and went
back into the infield of the race track
and did essentially what you and I
do on Memorial Day. They ran races.
They listened to 16 speeches by one count
and the troops marched back and forth
and they held picnics.
This was the first Memorial Day African
Americans invented Memorial Day in
Charleston,
South Carolina.
There are three or four cities in the
United States and north and south.
The claim to be the site
of the first Memorial Day,
but they all claim 1866
they were too late.
I had the great blind,
good fortune just to discover this
story in a messy totally disorganized
collection of veterans papers
at the Houghton Library
at Harvard some years back
and once you have there is black
Americans recently freed from slavery
announcing to the world where their
flowers and their feet and their songs,
what the war had been about.
What they basically were creating was
the independence day of a second American
revolution.
That story got lost.
Hey, got lost for more than a
century and one I discovered it.
I started calling people in Charleston
that I knew in archives and libraries,
including the Avery Institute,
the Black Research Center in Charleston.
He does anybody, do you have?
You've ever heard of this story?
And no one had ever heard it.
It showed the power of the lost cause in
the wake of the war to a race, a story,
but I started looking for other
sources and Lo and behold,
there were lots of sources.
Harper's weekly even had a drawing
of the cemetery in an 1867 issue.
The old oval of that race
track is still there today.
If you ever go to Charleston
and go up to Hampton Park,
Hampton Park is today what the race course
was then, its name for Wade Hampton,
the white supremacists,
Redeemer Governor of South Carolina
at the end of reconstruction and a
confederate general during the civil war,
and that park sits immediately
adjacent to the citadel,
the Military Academy of Charleston,
and any given day you can see at any
given time about a hundred or 200 citadel
jogging on the track
of the old race course.
There is no marker.
There's no memento is only
a little bit of a memory.
Although a few years ago a friend of
mine in Charleston organized a mock
ceremony where we reenacted that event
including the children's choir and they
made me dress up in a top hat and a funny
old 19th century suit and made me get
up on a podium and make a stupid speech.
Yeah,
but there is an effort,
at least today, yeah.
To declare a Hampton Park,
a national historic landmark.
See you Thursday.